on this saturday night the growing list
of canadian politicians in
hot water over holiday travel a
prominent member of the federal ndp is
stripped of her critic role
after traveling to greece this is a very
easy to understand
and very relevant standard the protest
at an ontario long-term care home
what's happening right now is horrific
concern and frustration mounts as
coveted case numbers
and the death toll rises the political
stories that could shape
2021. can the government get enough
canadians vaccinated
and a little boy receives a precious
gift from his father
who died seven years ago
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
colleen christie good evening thanks for
joining us
outrage is building over an expanding
list of officials flouting pandemic
travel restrictions
right now federal public health guidance
states all
non-essential travel outside of canada
is to be avoided
for months politicians have been telling
everyone to stay home
and yet that hasn't stopped some of them
from leaving
shawn o'shea is following the developing
details in our top story tonight
every time you take a trip it puts
people in jeopardy
with hospital intensive care units at or
near capacity government leaders have
pleaded please
stay at home when you can instead of
practicing what they preach
some politicians have been escaping the
canadian winter quietly jetting away
over the holidays
now a growing scandal in alberta someone
chose to travel with rules that were in
place that advised
otherwise three united conservative
party politicians decided to fly the
coop over christmas
for fun cabinet minister tracy allard
vacation in hawaii
so did parliamentary secretary jeremy
nixon the premier's own chief of staff
jamie huckabee went to britain last
month but so far
none is facing discipline i really don't
believe i can impose sanctions on
individuals who
did not violate the public health orders
or the law
it's just nakedly hypocritical and
that's why i think it's got such the
the resonant palpability that we're
feeling in manitoba
mp nikki ashton went to see her ailing
grandmother in greece
but didn't tell ndp leader jug meat
singh ahead of time
ashton was stripped of her critic role
as a result but ontario's finance
minister has paid the highest price for
his secret trip to saint bart's
an exclusive island in the caribbean
when the story got out ontario premier
doug ford expressed outrage
the next day admitting he knew shortly
after phillips arrived on the island
destination
i talked to him and asked where he was
he said he was away so this is going to
be an issue
my mistake phillips was ordered home and
resigned
significant error in judgment a dumb
dumb mistake for a trip to the beach and
a cheap daiquiri he's thrown it all away
like some other political vacationers
phillips used social media to make it
seem
like he was at home a very merry
christmas
phillips is now a comedic punch line on
social media
we all need to do st bart's i mean our
part
and with an air of woe is me calgary mp
michelle rempel gardner
bemoans because of politicians like
phillips now she can't travel to the
states
i'll just be selfish and say like thanks
rod i don't get to see my mother-in-law
now because there'll be a witch hunt if
i go see my family
tis the season when most of us heed the
warnings to stay at home
but many closer to power do not sean
o'shea global news toronto
the number of people testing positive in
ontario is growing breaking another
record today
more than 3 thousand people were
confirmed with the virus in the last 24
hours
the province also reported an additional
44 new deaths from covet 19.
the number of deaths from cobot 19 in a
long-term care facility east of toronto
has grown to 52 residents
the story sparked another protest today
outside the tender care living center
as morgan campbell reports families and
advocates have been calling for
additional staff
and military intervention kelvin long
says every day
he lives in fear of a single phone call
should i pick it up or not you know it
wouldn't be any good news
his mother is one of the dozens of
residents at toronto's tender care
living center
while she has not been diagnosed with
govid19
others at the facility have since
mid-december the disease has killed more
than 50 people
living there and sickened over a hundred
more
they helped build this country why are
we treating them like this
it's got to stop i don't work in
long-term care i don't have a relative
in here right now
but the thing is this could be any one
of us north york general
hospital took over management of the
home on christmas day
according to ontario's ministry of
long-term care staffing is now
above levels during normal operations
for personal support workers and
registered staff
infection prevention and control audits
have shown significant improvement
this week environmental services staff
are on site and continue to clean the
home
right now ontario is experiencing nearly
200 outbreaks in long-term care homes
that is one in three facilities
there have been multiple protests here
at tender care
over the last week advocacy groups and
family members
continue to call for not just government
accountability but military intervention
a move the ontario health coalition says
is imperative
as hospital resources are becoming
strained
due to community spread the staff have
to come from somewhere we cannot leave
these people
to starve to go without water to go
without
any respite from their pain or human
contact or care during the speech from
the throne the prime minister
committed to producing national
standards for long-term care homes
right now they are not part of the
canadian health act
which means provinces and territories
regulate facilities
and that's something i think that is
really important to have a set of
national standards
and working together families say that
is a step
toward a brighter future but it is the
present
they are concerned about my greatest
fear
is my mom dying alone morgan campbell
global news toronto
in the u.s there is growing concern over
the slow rollout of the covid vaccine
residents in several states report long
lines and being turned away as the
health system
struggles to keep up with the demand
jennifer johnson reports
frustration in chattanooga tennessee as
people 75 years and older
waited in long lines to be vaccinated
against covet 19
only to be turned away we were
determined to get it
but unfortunately it didn't happen cars
were backed up in florida
and arizona too where the department of
health's website crashed
kicking eligible people out it took me
four days
and i can't tell you how many tries to
try to get through the system because it
would go
through saying that there was no slots
available
vaccinations began in houston this
weekend for people over 65
but the city has only 750 spots for
approximately 190
000 senior citizens i know it can be
frustrating but
you know we're operating with what we
have and
and hopefully we'll get you know a lot
lot
more similar struggles in louisiana
which starts vaccinating some health
care workers
elderly and dialysis patients monday
this is going to be a limited release to
start
not everyone who is in these party
groups is going to be able to get
a vaccine next week the u.s has just
ended its deadliest
month of the pandemic and now begins
what experts say
will be an even deadlier january it's
like treading water from 100 feet below
the surface
you're already drowning but you just
have to keep trying because that's what
you can do
after internal oxygen systems began to
buckle at six hospitals
filled with cobit 19 patients
california's army corps of engineers had
to be calling to fix the problems
medical centers across the country
struggling to keep up
with so many sick and dying jennifer
johnson
global news washington india has
approved the kovit 19 vaccine developed
by astrazeneca and oxford university
it's the first to be given the green
light in that country india
is running a nationwide mock drill for
vaccine delivery today
the country hopes to inoculate 300
million people in the first half of the
year
india has more than 10 million coveted
cases second only
to the u.s in northern alberta
investigators are on the scene of a
fatal helicopter crash
rcmp say the chopper came down in a
farmers field
about 100 kilometers northeast of grand
prairie
the four occupants were confirmed dead
at the scene they are believed to be
from the same family
the cause of the crash remains under
investigation
two teenagers allegedly involved in the
death of a calgary police officer
made their first court appearances today
nineteen-year-old amir abdul rahman and
a 17 year old boy who cannot be
identified because of the youth criminal
justice act
briefly appeared via cctv they're
accused of murdering sergeant andrew
harnett
the officer died on new year's eve
shortly after being hit by an
suv allegedly driven by those fleeing a
traffic stop
arnett's brother says he was dedicated
to policing and
to his community he was
so proactive he was he was the type of
police officer
you'd want on the streets you know not
waiting for crime but looking for it and
trying to prevent it
andrew loved that city and uh
people are gonna are gonna miss a really
good dedicated officer
harnett's brother says the family hopes
to hold a huge celebration of life for
andrew
when it's allowed coming up the year
ahead in politics why it could be
a bumpy ride
from the downing of a ukrainian
passenger plane in iran and protests
over a pipeline through unseated
territory in bc to of course the
pandemic
this past year in politics has been like
no other
and now we look ahead to vaccine
distribution and
possibly an early election in a battered
economy
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stephenson
and our political correspondents take a
look at the political stories expected
to shape
2021. colleen
last year at this time we thought that
we had the busiest political year
imaginable
obviously here we are back in the same
seats a year later we haven't stopped
working since a year ago when we were
last in these seats although i will
point out for everyone at home
we are six feet apart those of us who
are in here at the desk
we have mike and abigail and at home
david joining us from
the david aiken studio special where he
has spent most of the pandemic
and uh wow what an incredible year i
mean we started out with a plane crash
where a plane with canadian citizens on
board was
shot down then we went into rail
blockades in some indigenous communities
after that covid 19 the crash of the
stalker the nova scotia shooting
crash of the snowbirds lost a finance
minister largest government programs in
canadian history being rolled out
a historic deficit that puts us back
with the second world war
and we're still in this pandemic no
election yet no budget those are on the
horizon
mike when you look at the year ahead in
2021 and we're all thankful that 2020 is
over but what do you see as being the
dominant story this year
it's really going to be how this
government emerges from the pandemic and
restarts the economy when do they decide
this is the time this is when we're
going to push the button and say okay
we're going to start this economy firing
again and making sure
that canada can re-emerge from this
stronger as the prime minister is saying
or will it sputter out of the gate that
i think will be something that canadians
will want to see
because think about it when we finally
say this pandemic is over or close
enough to being over that we can restart
everybody is going to want to travel to
get out to hug each other again
people will be dying to make sure that
we get going again so
when they decide okay this is when we
can do it i think will be the key
decision for this government
it's a huge political risk they've taken
which could either pay off tremendously
if the economy restarts and bounces back
or could be
a significant problem for them as they
move forward and nobody really knows yet
because we haven't seen it come out of
the second wave and the full economic
effects of that
but abigail i know one of the things
that you have been looking at not only
in this pandemic
but throughout your career has been
long-term care that was such a story of
2020 and we expect it will be again in
2021.
well you know that's right mike talks
about how the government is going to
emerge from this pandemic
i'm also interested in what lessons
we'll take with us from the pandemic
and long-term care is is something that
i'm very focused on because
you know the experts and the families
around and involved in the system have
been saying
for years that these exact problems of
chronic understaffing
not enough beds multiple beds in one
room people have been sounding the alarm
about those issues for years
and experts are saying that not enough
was even done between the first and the
second wave so
will there be big changes made to fix
some of these issues going forward
that's what i'll be watching for in 2021
and i think a lot of families will be
watching for that too and of course all
of us who one day will end up either
needing that kind of health care when
we're elderly or potentially being in
long-term care homes
so a personal interest in this for for
all canadians as well
david aiken i know there is uh something
you wanted to mention that didn't happen
in 2020 that normally happens that you
think will be a very big story
in 2021 what is that yeah
yeah there's a couple of things so of
course we didn't have a budget last year
in fact this trudeau government's gone
longer than any government in our
history in between budgets
but it looks like we're going to have
one in the spring and that's going to be
very important so that's a for certain
thing we're going to happen
and then very likely we'll see a general
election sometime in 2021
i think the likelihood of a general
election increases as the year goes on
although it could very well be dependent
on the economy and looking back
on 2020 don't forget we had three
provincial elections and that's an
that's a significant story
and we saw a majority government now in
place in bc
a majority government now in place in
new brunswick continued majority in
saskatchewan
those elections were important for
themselves but elections canada was
keeping an eye on
how they conducted those elections
safely during a pandemic
some lessons have been learned and
here's some lessons for the federal
politicians
three incumbents each of which were
perceived by their electorate
to be doing very well handling the
pandemic and they were rewarded with a
majority government
i think federally that's a lesson for
not just aaron o'toole and the
conservatives but justin trudeau and the
liberals
be careful if the public thinks the
federal government is generally going
the right way
on the pandemic they may reward the
incumbent with a majority
we have to take a quick pause in this
conversation but we will be back with
more right after this break
[Music]
you're watching global national
welcome back 2021 election speculation
vaccine rollout and ethical blind spots
the yearly ottawa correspondent
discussion continues now
well and it seems like so far the
federal opposition have been pretty shy
to call an election
they've been highly critical but at the
end of the day they have backed most of
the really big programs that were about
direct support to canadians the ndp has
been able to influence policy although
some say
they've taken a risk because they've
stepped down from taking the government
to the brink
that you know will people just associate
changes they've made to things like
pharmacare and sick days
with being the liberals mike how does
the opposition calculate whether or not
it's go time to pull the
trigger and go ahead to an election in
2021 i think it's really where we are in
the pandemic and
in the vaccination program because they
have to realize that
whoever decides now is the time they
will be painted as that
party during the election so if the
electorate says man i really
don't want to go to the polls right now
this is more trouble than it seems
then whoever has forced them to go to
the polls will pay the price
um i i think one of the interesting
things about a possible election will be
how does trudeau campaign how does
anybody campaign it could be more
digital
but prime minister trudeau is very
different from campaigning trudeau
who rolls up the sleeves gets out there
can whip up a crowd if there are no
crowds that he can whip up
then will he be a less effective
campaigner and thus pay
the price with seats in the house of
commons that's something that i think
will be really interesting
potential significant risk for the
government also potential opportunity
abigail where do you see this being that
the biggest opportunity for them to
i don't want to say score points but to
make gains politically with to be fair a
government that's been pretty popular
throughout this pandemic
that's right and i think uh in terms of
opportunity
the vaccine rollout is a big question
for me we've seen a lot of criticism of
the government for not providing
answers fast enough or not even being
clear about which answers they don't
have so
can the government get enough canadians
vaccinated to
develop mass immunity can they get
enough canadians who have questions you
know on-site and can they
physically actually get vaccines to
those who need it i think that's going
to be a big question
in 2021 you know all the experts are
fast to say this is the vaccine is not a
silver bullet
but it's the pretty much only thing in
this pandemic that's given a lot of
canadians hope so
will it roll out in an effective manner
i'd say that's something to watch
yeah everyone just wants to get back to
their lives david you know
risks the liberals often seem to run and
we've seen it year and year again
some of the judgment calls they make on
ethics files and in this case as well
they've put a very large
deficit out there do you think that
that's going to continue to be a big
issue the spending without being able to
answer where the money's coming from
and some of the choices that seem to be
getting made on these personal ethics
files like the wii scandal and losing a
finance minister
um almost certainly but whether or not
that seems to hurt the the trudeau
liberals politically
you know it's an open question i mean
again a year ago snc level that snc
level now we thought it would kill
trudeau and the liberals didn't
they want a government i think as we go
through the year think about this
um minority governments fall when one of
two things happens
the government thinks it can win a
majority and i don't see that right now
to win back the majority
the trudeau liberals would have to win a
lot of block seats in quebec
and none of the polls all in the last
year showed that the liberals were doing
that much better in quebec
the other way a government hap or an
election happens is the three opposition
parties think they can advance their own
uh seat count official opposition
becoming government the other parties
increasing the number of seats do we
really think the ndp is in a position to
start picking up seats
i'm not so sure the bq is probably at a
high water mark
i don't think they're necessarily hungry
maybe the conservatives but the point is
all three opposition parties have to
come to the conclusion at the same time
they can eat some government lunch
that's going to be tricky to see that
calculus i think in the spring
maybe more so in the fall we have to
wrap it up there but we'll certainly be
keeping a close eye on all of these
issues thank you very much to our
correspondents for all their hard work
throughout the year we'll see you back
here next year
that's all the time we have for today so
back to you colleen
coming up next a boy and a very special
gift
the story that proves holiday miracles
can't happen
a bc boy is starting his new year with a
very special gift from his dad
one that arrived seven years after his
father died
grace key explains how a mystery santa
made a father's wish finally come true
and little boy's christmas very special
nine-year-old charlie got a very special
gift this christmas from a mysterious
steepstone elf i figured it out by just
putting my finger
right there his father paul bought this
guitar seven
years ago for charlie but weeks before
christmas paul died from injuries
resulting
from a workplace accident when it came
time to wrap
presents i saw this guitar and
i just couldn't couldn't give it to
charlie it was too painful
erica sold the guitar in a facebook
auction and doesn't remember who bought
it
paul was an amateur musician and hoped
one day to teach charlie how to play
charlie lives with autism he was just
two years old when his father died
my dad that died seven years ago would
give me this guitar
to to teach me how to play the guitar
[Music]
a few days before christmas someone
wrapped the guitar and left it on the
doorstep
addressed to charlie not knowing what
was inside
erica put it under the tree and then on
christmas
day when charlie opened it erica
recognized it right away
they were kind of looking at me like why
are you crying
and so i read the the note to them
and then saw looked over at charlie and
he was sitting on the couch already
playing
with the guitar
dearest charlie we bought it for a
purpose and kept it through the years
waiting for you to grow up
it was always yours thank you very very
very
much this makes this make
this makes me feel very happy
grace key global news sweet
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm colleen christie
tonight's your canada is a sign of hope
from kamloops bc
if you'd like to share your canada with
us please email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thanks for watching have a good night
[Music]